que c'est encore une signe que les
forces ukrainiennes progressent
lentement mais sûrement aux alentours de
bac mouth mais on arrive qu'à c'est
vraiment une localité très petite ce
n'est pas une Persée qui change la donne
et puis encore plus important de
souligner c'est que même si pakmout a
une importance symbolique c'est vraiment
dans le sud que les vrais cibles
stratégiques de cette contre-offensive
se trouve et là il n'y a pas eu de
progrès significatif ces derniers jours
en ce moment à keV le mot d'ordre chez
les militaires comme chez les politiques
et plutôt de préparer l'opinion publique
et les partenaires de l'Ukraine à la
possibilité d'une guerre longue qui va
encore durer des mois voire des années
tout en gardant l'espoir d'une percée
rapide de quelque chose qui pourrait
faire accélérer les choses mais c'est
plutôt dans cette guerre d'usure que les
Ukrainiens ont affiché des succès ces
derniers jours dans la destruction de
objets russes à longue distance
notamment en Crimée ou au moins un
navire aurait été touché dans le port de
sévastopol et un système de défense
anti-aérienne de type S400 qui sont des
systèmes très importants et très
puissants cela fait maintenant la
deuxième que les Ukrainiens ont réussi à
détruire de l'équipement russe en Crimée
et puis on Ukraine proprement dit mais
dans la partie occupée de la région de
zapporisa il y a eu des explosions ce
matin dans la ville de Melito Paul qui
est l'une des cibles stratégiques de
l'Ukraine peut-être qu'ils ont détruit
une base ou un objet stratégique russe
amélito Paul ce ne serait pas la
première fois mais pour le moment je
n'ai pas plus de détails
allez céréales ukrainiennes aujourd'hui
expire le moratoire accordé par l'Union
européenne à des pays comme la Pologne
qui leur permettait de ne pas importer
de céréales ukrainiennes pour préserver
leur propre agriculteurs Varsovie d'y
vouloir prolonger cette embargo coûte
que coûte comme en Kiev va réagir
je pense que Varsovie est bien décidée à
faire cavalier seul et à prolonger cet
embargo les Polonais disent qu'il était
absolument nécessaire parce que
l'arrivée des produits Ukrainiens sur le
marché polonais des produits qui avant
le début de l'invasion à grande échelle
était exporté plutôt vers le moyen-or et
d'autres pays plus loin par la voie de
la mer Noire et bien a fait chuter les
prix mettons en danger les agriculteurs
polonais qui event et pas uniquement qui
est aussi d'autres pays de l'Union
européenne dénonce un populisme
préélectoral en Pologne disons que les
Polonais exagèrent l'impact des
importations
ukrainien sur les prix que la baisse des
prix est aussi le résultat de d'autres
facteurs qui a dit que c'est une que ce
n'est pas en accord avec les lois du
commerce international et menacent de
saisir l'OMC